o alecrim é um incrível remédio natural
usado em vários problemas digestórios
como perdra de apetite aia ou refluxo áo
também gases inchaço e dores abdominais
ainda é capaz de estimular a liberação
de fluidos digestivos incluindo abile e
auxilia na digestão e atua na absorção
de nutrientes além de utilizar o alrm
adicionando o tempero em pratos outra
forma interessante de uso é através de
infusão em água quente ou seja o famoso
chazinho a infus funciona como um
remédio natural para tratar os problemas
da digestão Recomendo muito o uso do chá
ou a tintura de alecrim para tratar o
refluxo os gases e a zia e essa Melhora
você pode sentir em apenas três semanas
de uso